this video continues my series about the
various types of regular sound changes
that happen over time and language last
time we considered situations where
existing sounds became more or less
similar to one another assimilation and
assimilation this time it's all about
sounds that get added to or deleted from
words
when a sound is added to a word that's
called a pen thesis the new phoneme is
an empathetic sound for instance you may
have heard some English speakers add an
epithet ik are to the word sherbet
pronouncing it sherbert not all added
sounds are the same is the additional
sound of vowel that's an optics Asst
Sardinian speakers changed Rosa to add
Rosa by adding an an optic thick vowel
to the front of the word is the added
sound a consonant if so that's called
excrescence ancient Greek speakers
sometimes pronounce their word s T as
esteem adding an excrescence consonant
not all in pentas this happens in the
same place either
if the phoneme is added to the beginning
of a word it's called prothesis the
Sardinian example Arosa
adds a prophetic ah if the phoneme is
added to the end of a word it's called
para goji the ancient Greek word esteem
as a Paragon
M elision happens when a sound is
removed from a word the lost phoneme is
said to be alighted or deleted the final
buh sound has been alighted from the
English word thumb compare the book and
thimble is the phoneme removed from the
beginning of a word that's apheresis for
example English speakers may shorten
about time to about time
is the sound removed from the middle of
Ord this kind of Alishan is known as
syncope this luiseño word meaning the
Bears is pronounced whom would me
speakers syncopate that middle who is
the phoneme removed from the end of a
word that change gets called
apakah P so the word thumb losing its
final but over time is an example of
apakah P
so this has been a quick ground-level
understanding of appendices and elision
in the next video I'll pick out a few
types of sound changes we haven't
cleaned so far